hello everyone and welcome to an
absolute master class from round three
of the 2022
uh air things masters it's andreas penco
versus magnus carlsen and it's uh well
uh uh
it's been a while since we've seen a
game this good and this precise it
features the two nice defense and uh
well you you guys will enjoy it
immensely it's very short or rather not
maybe very short it's like 45 moves but
the
it's just a completely lost position
very very
early on in the game which is always
impressive against the world champion so
let's see uh how how this played out the
spinkle with the white pieces opens with
e4 we have e5 by magnus knight to f3
knight to c6 and bishop the c4 now
asking for the for the um joko piano to
go for the evans gambit most likely but
magnus denies it and he goes for knight
to f6 he goes for the two knights
defense
and now even though knight to g5 is
everyone's favorite idea uh here we have
d3 the so-called modern bishops opening
bishop to e7 and both players castle so
castles castles and now it's uh who
knows what and and how how well uh rook
to e1 by far the most popular idea is
panko already going for a very nice
sideline with knight to c3 d6 and now uh
the very early a4 and now it's very hard
to say i mean this is this has so many
branches if magnus knows by heart what's
um
what's going on here he goes a5 which is
again a standard reply in many of these
um
well positions and now rook to e1 we
have knight to b4
uh well you've played a4 so you there's
no way for for white to challenge the
knight on b4 for the moment although
when this knight moves you can always
play c3 and now knight to e2 uh already
preparing the very early uh
c3 push and now we have bishop e6
interestingly uh the position has been
reached uh uh in in last year uh in the
european team championship where bishop
to g4 was played in in a game between
van forest and
even issued which in the like i said
european team championship uh van forest
won that game but here we have bishop to
e6 and it is now as of move nine that we
have a completely new game so let's see
how is panko deals with this we have
bishop captures on e6 this will double
black spawns but okay it's not a problem
if anything you will have uh well future
support for uh for your d5 advancement
knight to g3 uh continuing development
and now knight back the c6 as the magnus
is most likely preparing to push d5 he
wants his e5 pawn nicely defended so c3
the knight would get kicked away either
way and now is pink also preparing d4
and here knight to d7 and this is a bit
of an odd move here magnus might play
something like queen to d7 to
uh develop the queen to connect the
rooks and then maybe
uh to figure out where to go from there
but he plays knight to d7 which is not
that odd but after bishop to e3 he
retreats the knight with knight to f6 so
maybe knight to d7 was a mouse slip
maybe he intended queen to d7 it's hard
to say although it's not easy to explain
this maneuver but okay now uh you might
say okay but now you have the two
weaknesses here maybe queen to b3 can be
played and we can exploit this the
problem is uh even though queen to b3 is
an excellent move you don't really get
to win anything because after queen d7
and yes the queen does belong on d7 you
can't capture on b7 because rook have to
be eight and the queen is trapped so uh
you can play queen to b3 you just don't
win any pawns so instead after knight f6
d4 by esibenko uh e captures on d for c
captures and now d5 by magnus finally
pushing that pawn uh and now before
advancing the pawn to e5 first knight to
g5 the e6 is a backward spawn it's a
very weak pawn and now magnus will have
to defend it finally
by playing queen to d7 as uh he most
likely intended so e5 uh challenging the
knight now and where where do you put
the knight there really isn't a good
square because both of these knights are
now guarding the e4 square so we have to
go back knight back to e8 uh and now uh
ispinko wants to bring more firepower
like queen to g sorry queen the g4 would
be nice going after that e6 pawn but
this would allow magnus to just trade
for example captures the bishop captures
queen f7 and it's uh
uh well
all of a sudden not so not so bad for
black uh but yes penguin just brings the
knight back knight stage three and he
will play queen g4 and bring this knight
over to f4 to go after the e6 weakness
and magnus
will have a hard time stopping this so
here magnus plays rook to a6 he wants to
play rook to b6 and go after this b2
pawn so activating his rook and now
queen g4 as planned we have looked a b6
by magnus going after the b2 pawn and
now knight to f4 asking magnus
what do you play here and how do you
defend your e6 weakness
and magnus doesn't defend magnus just
captured on b2 the other option is just
plain knight to d8 and for the moment
defend it and try to play this passive
position uh which might be better but in
a rapid game uh how better is a passive
position it's it's hard to say so
instead after knight to f4 we have rook
captures on b2 by magnus and now
uh queen captures on e6 this comes with
check and you have to capture otherwise
you're just gonna lose the queen on
these seven so captures captures
attacking the rook rook f7 and now rook
eat the c1 paralyzing the knight here if
the knight moves then the c7 pawn it
will become very vulnerable so here g6
yeah and now rook a to b1 uh forcing the
rook either to move or to uh capture on
b1 and then we will have another rook on
b1 going after the b7 pawn so really
really uh pretty much completely
paralyzing uh all of um will all the
entire board really so here rook
captures on b1 rook captures attacking
the b7 pawn
we have knight to b4 so you don't have
to defend the pawns no now the the
knight is blocking the attack and now
comes knight to e2 uh and here it's a
very very difficult position for magnus
not a lot of uh
not a lot to play for here
but it still can be uh if if played
maybe to a perfection but here magnus
played c6 and now
it's just a
positionally lost game but you have to
find the absolute best move and that is
well that's often what it takes to take
down a world champion so feel free to
pause the video here and try to spot
this idea uh yes pink or may or may not
have played while i give you a couple of
seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotting this
uh unimaginably uh difficult move to
spot and for those of you who just want
to enjoy the show it is bishop to all
the way to h6 that's the good stuff and
finding this move well that's not easy
as you think of played this fairly
quickly uh the idea is that you have to
prevent this knight from coming to g7 if
you play something else let's say you
try knight to f4 uh now we're gonna play
knight g7 and already black's position
is a little bit easier to play for
example captures capture cs you can get
96 checking goes back and it's not great
for black but it's not lost so isipenko
founded the the very difficult bishop to
h6 and now what do you play without
knight to g7 what moves are there you
can't push pawns you can't move the
knight because the b7 pawn hangs
the knight has nowhere to go all of the
squares are taken what do you have can
the bishop go somewhere can the can the
rook go somewhere you could play bishop
to f8 just uh attacking but that means
also giving up the exchange so not much
fun there so here magnus tries rook f5
he wants to play rook the h5 and kick
away the bishop but isipenko just stops
it he plays a g4
also also maybe interesting with f4 but
the g4 gets the job done as well we have
rook to f3 and now bishop back to e3
preventing the rook from going anywhere
and now we're
preparing a knight to f4 when the knight
jumps to f4 the rook will be trapped on
f3 and then king g2 will just uh well
attacked the rook will have to be given
up for for the night or the or for the
bishop or the knight so here we have
king to f7 if you try knight g7 now yes
you can now you can play it because the
bishop is on e3 uh we're just going to
capture and after king captures knight
f4 like we mentioned then we're going to
win material so instead after bishop to
e3 we have kink the f7
uh also you could try uh rook to f7
because uh well we we are trying to save
our rook then we're going to play knight
to f4 and after finally knight to g7 now
we play this captures captures knight e6
checking after king g8 f4 and now it's a
little bit different it's similar to the
position that we've discussed only uh
here we have f4 and g4 included and that
of course is much much better for white
so okay instead in the actual game after
bishop e3 king to f7 was played now
comes knight six the f4 uh challenging
this rook here now we are ready to play
king to g2 so g5 uh magnus tries to uh
to save the rook somehow knight the h5
and now king the g8 freeing up the f8
square for the rook so king to g2 and
now rook to f8 and okay in this line of
events that the rook has been saved but
it's not going to be easy to hold on
because of h4
and now you are just threatening to win
a pawn if pawn captures here then we're
just gonna play bishop h6 attack the
rook then f4 f5 and there's no stopping
those pawns so instead magnus played h6
uh time to defend the g5 pawn but now
knight eat the g3 just mounting the
pressure uh then i can come to f5 then
to h6 but putting pressure on e7 so here
king f7 by magnus now knight to f5
rook to h8 guarding the h6 spawn but it
is simply not enough there is too much
pressure knight captures on e7 king
captures and of course h captures and g5
and now everything falls apart we have h
captures bishop captures and g5 would
check king to f7 and now f4
we have looked at g8 uh trying to stop
the advancement because the bishop hangs
but now just king to g3 we are bringing
our king into the game knight c7 trying
to activate the knight but not knight to
f6 attacking the rook rook g7 bishop to
h6 again attacking the rook rook the g6
and now g5
preparing to bring the king into the
game also f5 will be very scary so
knight to e6 and now magnus will
doesn't really have any more moves
because f5 was played
and i believe here magnus resigned
because the rook captures on f6 is the
last move in the game so maybe magnus
just picked it up and said ah whatever
you know just place it anywhere so maybe
he resigned here maybe he resigned after
capturing but uh
uh all in all it was in this position on
move 44 that magnus carlsen resigned the
game and what uh two nights defense
master class or rather uh against a two
nights defense master class by andre
sipenko uh because after uh for example
captures on f6 there's not much you can
capture on d4 but look at the pawns here
they're just monsters you're up the
exchange so there's not much let's say
king g4 b5 uh and the whatever now
bishop e3 we can attack the knight
knight moves we're going to play king g5
and now we don't even care where you can
give up this then e6 check king the e8
uh the pawns are just too strong you can
play whatever rook h1 checkmate is
coming pawns are coming so it doesn't
really matter it's completely winning
for espanko so of course uh here or here
magnus resigned the game and what a
brilliant victory
uh so yeah uh i thought it was going to
be another another uh
joko piano or joko pianissimo butt and
it was the two nice defense and it was a
very very impressive one uh showing that
what uh what a dangerous opening it can
still be regardless of how much theory
you know because magnus really knows a
lot of theory especially against such
old openings like like the two knights
defense he probably knows all the theory
but not not really all the theory
because uh well espanko chose a really
really uh
nice sideline here going for knight c3
instead of the main rook to e1 and then
after this going for the very early a4
and there are maybe a handful of games
with this exact same move order so that
was enough to take magnus magnus out
and also of course he had to play uh you
know
a great chess aft after all of this uh
so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it i would like to thank odell
lucifer 45 non-commercial ep dale cook
uh onward the 95 american flag numa and
the david kimura for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the air
things masters uh checking up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the chess world so thank you
all i will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day and if you
have any questions against air things do
use hashtag airthings and just ask the
question in the comments
see you soon